I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi everybody. Hey there. You guys, I'm so excited to be here today. Not that I'm not always excited, but I don't know, I just really enjoyed this episode. It cracked me up. I liked it too. It was a surprise to me. I had kind of a little bit forgotten about this one. Yeah, I hadn't seen this in a good while. So it was just fun to be an audience.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部名为《终极办公室重温》的播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。你们好呀。伙计们，我今天太兴奋能来到这里了。倒不是说我平时不兴奋，但怎么说呢，我真的很喜欢这一集。它让我笑个不停。我也很喜欢。这对我来说是个惊喜。我把这一集忘得差不多了。对啊，我好久没看这一集了。所以能以观众的身份来看真的很有趣。
Well, let's tell everyone what we're talking about today. It is Money Part 1, which is season four, episode seven, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Paul Lieberstein. Yes. Should I hit you with a summary? I was hoping you would. I knew you were. I knew you wouldn't let it go by without a summary. A great summary. I would never. An amazing summary by me? I'm hoping for a summary and three fast facts. I mean, come on. Oh, lady, you're going to be happy. Good. I'm going to sip my tea and listen and only judge a little. Go for it. What? All right, here we go. Here's the summary. Michael is forced to confront his money woes as Jan renovates his condo. He has to take a second job as a telemarketer. Pam and Jim spend a night
好了，让我们告诉大家我们今天要聊的内容。那就是第四季第七集《金钱（上）》，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧并执导。没。我来给你讲个梗概吧？我正希望你这么做呢。我知道你会的。我知道你绝不会让它没有梗概就过去。一个精彩的梗概。我才不会呢。由我带来的惊艳梗概？我希望能有一个梗概和三个快讯。我是说，拜托。哦，女士，你会高兴的。很好。我要喝口茶，听着，然后稍微做点评。开始吧。什么？好吧，我们开始吧。梗概是这样的。迈克尔被迫面对自己的财务危机，因为简在翻修他的公寓。他不得不兼职做电话推销员。潘和吉姆度过了一个夜晚
at Dwight's Family Beat Farm, which he is now running as a bed and breakfast. Kelly and Daryl work on their relationship and Andy tries to woo Angela. Thank you. Any judgments? Any judgments? No, no, no. Oh, not yet. Good. So far. All right. Well, fast fact number one. Now, I mentioned that this episode was written by Paul and directed by Paul, but this was actually the first episode directed by Paul Lieberstein. Yeah. So he will go on to direct many more, but this was his office directorial debut. Oh, gee. Yeah. So I reached out to him because I was like, I mean, he wrote it. He directed it. Let's hear from him. Yeah. And he told me that he wrote this episode while he was on vacation in Russia. What? Yeah. I didn't know he'd ever vacationed
在德怀特的家族甜菜农场，他现在把那里经营成了一家住宿加早餐旅馆。凯利和达里尔修复了他们的关系，安迪则试图追求安吉拉。谢谢。有什么评价吗？有什么评价吗？没有，没有，没有。哦，还没有。目前没有。好吧。好吧，快讯一。现在，我提到这一集是由保罗编剧并执导的，但实际上这是保罗·利伯斯坦执导的第一集。是的。所以他后来会执导更多集，但这确实是他在《办公室》的导演处女作。哦，天哪。是的。所以我联系了他，因为我想，我是说，他编剧的。他执导的。让我们听听他的说法。是的。他告诉我，这一集是他在俄罗斯度假时写的。什么？是的。我不知道他还在
in Russia. Paul would have been a really interesting thing to banter about while we were on set, waiting for lights to go up and stuff. He's holding back. I did know he'd been to Russia. Oh. So there you go. How was it? Was it great? It was great. He had a great, great time. Well, he said that he was so excited to be able to write and direct this episode because it featured the first visit to Dwight's farmhouse at Shrewt Farms because we've been there. We saw the barn in the initiation and all that, but he got to completely invent Dwight's home and what it looked like and all of that stuff. And he said that he got the idea for Dwight to run a bed and breakfast during a trip to Italy a couple of years before. He is a world traveler. He is well traveled.
俄罗斯度过假。保罗，我们在片场等待灯光亮起之类的间隙，这会是一个非常有趣的话题。他有所保留。我知道他去过俄罗斯。哦。所以你看。怎么样？棒极了？太棒了。他玩得非常、非常开心。嗯，他说他很高兴能编写和执导这一集，因为它展现了对什鲁特农场德怀特农舍的第一次访问，因为我们去过那里。我们在《入会仪式》里见过谷仓诸如此类的，但他得以完全凭空创造出德怀特的家以及它是什么样子的等等所有这些。他说，他让德怀特经营一家住宿加早餐旅馆的想法来自于几年前的一次意大利之旅。他是个世界旅行家。他游历广泛。
Yes. So while he was in Italy, he had seen a bunch of signs for this farm B&B stay. You go stay on people's farms in Italy. Sounds amazing. I just want Paul to know if you're listening, Paul, you don't have to go all the way to Italy for that. You can have a farm B&B right here. I'm sure like my family farm in Texas would take you in. I would love to have a farm B&B experience at your parent's farm. I would love that so much. I would love to get up in the morning and go check on the cows with you. Oh, lady, you're speaking my language. Well, Paul just said he loved imagining Dwight as a proprietor of a bed and breakfast. And he also told me he did so much to prepare for this episode.
是的。所以在意大利期间，他看到了许多关于这种农场B&B住宿的标志。你可以去意大利人们的农场住宿。听起来太棒了。我只是想让保罗知道，如果你在听的话，保罗，你没必要为了这个大老远跑到意大利去。你可以在这里就有一家农场B&B。我敢肯定，比如我在德克萨斯的家族农场就会收留你。我很想在你父母的农场体验一次农场B&B。我会非常喜欢那样的。我很想早上起床跟你一起去查看奶牛。哦，女士，你真说到我心坎里去了。嗯，保罗只是说他很喜欢把德怀特想象成一家住宿加早餐旅馆的老板。他还告诉我，为了这一集他做了很多准备工作。
He really like overprepared because it was just a really big deal to him and he wanted it to be full of so many details and it was. Oh yes, there's so many cool details and we're going to point them out to you as they come up. Definitely. All right. Fast fact number two is a location breakdown. I knew this was coming. The Shroot Farms location breakdown. I have been to this farm many times. Let's hear what you got. So we mentioned before that we shot Shroot Farms on the Disney Ranch in Santa Clarita, California. We went back for this episode and this time we used the Olivia's house location. That is the farmhouse that we transformed into Dwight's B&B. Yes, you guys should know this is a vast property and they have different areas where they film. So they have the
他真的像是过度准备了，因为这对他是件大事，他希望里面充满各种细节，确实如此。哦，是的，有很多很酷的细节，等它们出现时我们会向你们指出。一定的。好吧，快讯二是一个取景地解析。我就知道会这样。什鲁特农场取景地解析。我来过这个农场很多次。让我们听听你有什么料。所以我们之前提到过，我们在加州圣克拉里塔的迪士尼牧场拍摄了什鲁特农场。我们为这一集回到了那里，这次我们使用了奥利维亚的房子这个取景地。这就是我们改造为德怀特B&B的那栋农舍。是的，你们应该知道，这是一个巨大的地产，他们有不同的区域用于拍摄。所以他们有
barn, right, where you saw the initiation. And then they have little houses and different areas that you can use to create sort of this rustic look for TV and film. But these houses, they're just shells. There's nothing in them. Nothing. They're just like exterior shell walls. The walls are not insulated. So it got very, very cold at night. Any of the night scenes, we were freezing. Freezing and drafty and everything is a little bit dusty. Like if you sit on something like a little cloud of like, yeah, it kind of comes out of it. And our set designers had to go in and they had to meticulously decorate every single room. Every item you see, we put there. That's right. That's right. I have a feeling they went in first and cleaned and then decorated. Why is my memory
谷仓，对吧，你在《入会仪式》里看到那个。然后他们有小房子和不同的区域，可以用来为电视和电影营造这种乡村风格。但这些房子，它们只是空壳。里面什么都没有。什么都没有。它们就像是外墙壳子。墙壁没有做隔热。所以晚上非常、非常冷。任何夜间场景，我们都在瑟瑟发抖。冻得要命，四面透风，而且每样东西都带点灰尘。就像如果你坐在什么东西上面，就会有一小团……对吧，它会从里面冒出来。我们的布景设计师不得不进去，精心装饰每一个房间。你看到的每一件物品，都是我们放进去的。没错。没错。我有种感觉，他们先进去打扫然后才进行装饰。为什么我的记忆中
of Shroop Farm so dusty? Well, I remember sneezing a lot. It's dusty. It's old. It's run down. You know, you wouldn't want to lean against the wall. I'll just say that. No. You might go right through it. He might. Now, we have another location in this episode. Michael takes a job as a telemarketer. And I asked Kentepedia about this location. The exterior, when you see him walking into the building, we shot that in Van Nuys. That was near our studio. But the inside of the building, we shot on the 10th floor of the LA Times building in downtown LA. Now, this shocked me. This shocked me because this building is stunning. Stunning. It housed the LA Times until 2017. It was designed by this man named Gordon B. Kaufman in the Art Deco style in the 1930s.
什鲁特农场那么尘土飞扬？嗯，我记得我打了很多喷嚏。很尘土飞扬。很旧。破败不堪。你知道的，你不会想靠在墙上。我只能这么说。不。你可能会直接穿墙而过。他可能会。现在，我们在这一集中还有另一个取景地。迈克尔找了一份电话推销员的工作。我向肯特百科询问了这个取景地。外观，当你看到他走进大楼时，我们在凡尼斯拍摄的。那离我们的工作室很近。但大楼内部，我们在洛杉矶市中心洛杉矶时报大楼的第10层拍摄的。现在，这震惊了我。这震惊了我，因为这栋建筑美极了。美极了。它曾是《洛杉矶时报》的总部，直到2017年。它是由一个叫戈ードン·B·考夫曼的人在20世纪30年代以装饰艺术风格设计的。
It won a gold medal at the 1937 Paris Exposition. And it's so weird to me that this very ordinary telemarketing office is housed inside of this gorgeous piece of architecture. I know. That is so wild because we don't do that building justice at all. We make it look just like like any cubicle office anywhere, right? Yeah. Well, I shot a commercial in my 20s in downtown LA. And I was really stunned because it was a gorgeous building and we were shooting on like the 12th floor. And then they had like craft and service on a different floor, you know, they used a few floors. And it was like three floors in a row with no people, no one. Wow. So I think there are like sort of buildings downtown that have just a lot of vacancy. Yeah, there must be.
它在1937年巴黎世博会上赢得了金牌。这让我觉得非常奇怪，这个非常普通的电话推销办公室竟然坐落在这么一块华丽的建筑艺术品里面。我知道。太疯狂了，因为我们根本没有把那栋建筑拍出它的气势。我们把它拍得就像任何地方的普通隔间办公室一样，对吧？是的。嗯，我20岁时在洛杉矶市中心拍过一个商业广告。我真的很震惊，因为那是一栋宏伟的建筑，我们是在大约12层拍摄的。然后他们在另一层有剧组餐饮服务之类的，你知道，他们用了好几层。就像连续三层楼空无一人，一个人也没有。哇。所以我觉得市中心有些建筑就是有大量的空置率。是的，一定是的。
I know. It was really eerie because we were filming at night and it was like a dark corridor. Well, I visited the LA Times back in college as part of a film and television summer workshop that was coordinated by UCLA. And we got to go in and see how they make newspapers. And I remember the lobby. It has this great big globe and I have all these pictures. It was just amazing. I would love that. I would sign up for that. Yeah. I mean, you know, I love a tour. We would sign up for almost any tour, I feel like. We would. I mean, I feel like we could do a podcast where it's just you and I taking tours and talking about today we went to the peanut factory. Oh, lady, that's a brilliant idea. We have to do that. We travel and go on tours and then tell
我知道。真的有点诡异，因为我们是在晚上拍摄，那就像是一条黑暗的走廊。嗯，我上大学时曾作为UCLA协调的电影和电视夏季研讨会的一部分参观过《洛杉矶时报》。我们得以进去看他们是如何制作报纸的。我记得大厅。那里有一个很大的地球仪，我有很多照片。简直太棒了。我会很喜欢那个。我会报名参加。是的。我是说，你知道的，我喜欢参观。我觉得我们几乎可以做这样一个播客：只有你和我去参观各种地方，然后谈论今天我们去了花生工厂。哦，女士，这是一个绝妙的主意。我们一定要这么做。我们旅行并参观，然后告诉
people about the tour we went on. I mean, selfishly, I want to do that. That sounds great. Okay. Okay. Well, speaking of travel, fast fact number three, TripAdvisor features very heavily in this episode. Yes. And I want you guys to know we really did create a page on the real TripAdvisor for Shroot Farms. And our producers made two profiles and gave two reviews. So you could go on after watching the episode and see these two reviews and see the page. We hear one of them in the episode. That's the one from Jim and Pam. And their profile name was J and P2. But the other one that you don't hear in the episode, Angela, was from Sprinkles Mom. I know. And it's a really negative review. It's very negative. Did you find it too? I did. It says, stay away. The proprietor is crazy.
人们我们参观的经历。自私地说，我想这么做。听起来好极了。好吧。好吧，说到旅行，快讯三，猫途鹰（TripAdvisor）在本集中占了很大比重。是的。我想让你们知道，我们真的在真实的猫途鹰上为什鲁特农场创建了一个页面。我们的制片人创建了两个个人资料并写了两条评论。所以你们在看完这一集后可以上去看看这两条评论和这个页面。我们在这一集中听到了其中一条。那是吉姆和潘写的。他们的用户名是J and P2。但另一条你在剧中听不到的，安吉拉，是来自洒水喷头妈妈（Sprinkles Mom）。我知道。而且这是一条非常负面的评论。非常负面。你也找到了吗？找到了。上面写着，远离这里。老板是个疯子。
Oh my gosh, you have to read it. You have to read it. Okay. It says, I have to warn people about the proprietor of Shroot Farms. He may portray himself as a gentleman farmer, but he is not what he seems. He killed my cat, Sprinkles. Who knows what he might do to you or your loved ones. So the profiles are no longer there and those reviews are no longer there. But Shroot Farms is still a page on TripAdvisor. It has over 1,300 reviews and it has four stars. I went on the Shroot Farms TripAdvisor page and I want you guys to know it's got a little write up. It's got a photo. This is something that cracked me up. It says, here are the languages spoken at Shroot Farms. Are you ready? I'm ready. Now, we know this is just Dwight and Moe's,
哦，天哪，你得读一下。你得读一下。好吧。上面写着，我必须警告人们关于什鲁特农场老板的事。他可能把自己伪装成一个绅士农夫，但他并非表面上那样。他杀死了我的猫，洒水喷头。谁知道他对你或你的挚爱会做出什么事。所以这些个人资料已经不在了，那些评论也已经不在了。但什鲁特农场仍然是猫途鹰上的一个页面。它有1300多条评论，而且有四星评分。我上了什鲁特农场猫途鹰页面，我想让你们知道上面有一段简短介绍。还有一张照片。这让我笑喷了。上面写着，以下是什鲁特农场使用的语言。准备好了吗？我准备好了。现在，我们知道这只是德怀特和莫斯的，
but here are the languages spoken. Okay. Azerbaijan, Bosnian, Burmese, Hebrew, Hindi, Hungarian, Icelandic, Portuguese. Oddly, not on the list is German and Dwight answers the phone Guten Tag. So TripAdvisor, you might want to update that. TripAdvisor is like, guys, this is surreal. We just agreed to do it. And then the other thing I thought was kind of cool about this and it's a little bit of a callback. This was also a task in the Dunder Mifflin Infinity online game. Posting review of Shroot Farms was part of Dunder Mifflin Infinity's game on their website. That is so cool. And you can still post, as Jenna said, your review today. And I just read one as recent as December 2020, someone made up a review. Now, I read one, Angela, and I wasn't
但以下是他们使用的语言。好吧。阿塞拜疆语、波斯尼亚语、缅甸语、希伯来语、印地语、匈牙利语、冰岛语、葡萄牙语。奇怪的是，名单上没有德语，而德怀特接电话时说“Guten Tag”（德语：你好）。所以猫途鹰，你们可能需要更新一下了。猫途鹰就像是，伙计们，这太超现实了。我们刚同意这么做。然后我觉得这件事很酷的另一点是，这是一个小彩蛋。这也是《办公室：无限》在线游戏中的一个任务。在什鲁特农场发布评论是《办公室：无限》在其网站上的游戏的一部分。太酷了。正如珍娜所说，你今天仍然可以发表你的评论。我刚刚读到了一条2020年12月份的最新评论，有人编造了一条评论。现在，我读到了一条，安吉拉，我当时不确定
sure if it was real or not. Oh yeah? But a person wrote, guys, this place is not real. I drove all the way there and there is nothing there. And I was very disappointed. Oh no. And I was like, wait, wait, did this person really drive to this weird remote location in Pennsylvania hoping to find Shroot Farms? You've got to know there's at least one person, right, that doesn't know that it was part of the show and just is wanting to go see it, right? Yeah. Oh, sorry person who drove there. Sorry, buddy. Well, that's all I got, lady. Well, I thought those were fantastic fast facts. No judgy. No judgy, lady. Oh, I get a no judgy and no judgy for you today. That is high praise. Well, before we go to break, we have some great news to share with you guys. It's
它是真是假。哦，是吗？但一个人写道，伙计们，这个地方不是真的。我大老远开车去那儿，结果什么都没有。我非常失望。哦，不。我就想，等等，等等，这个人真的开车去了宾夕法尼亚这个偏僻奇怪的地方，希望能找到什鲁特农场吗？你得知道至少有一个人，对吧，不知道这是节目的一部分，只是想去看看，对吧？是的。哦，对不起那个开车的家伙。对不起，老兄。好吧，这就是我所有的料了，女士。嗯，我觉得这些都是棒极了的快讯。没有评判。没有评判，女士。哦，我今天得到了一个“没有评判”也回赠你一个“没有评判”。这可是极高的赞誉。好吧，在我们休息之前，我们有一些好消息要与大家分享。这
very exciting. I'm very excited. I'm very excited. Thanks to the Office Ladies fans. We won iHeart Radio's podcast of the year. Podcast of the year, guys. Of the year. Thank you so much for voting for us. You really have no idea how excited we are about this. We are very, very proud. I mean, lady, we put our heart into this podcast every week. We do. And I am going to cherish this award and put it in a very prominent spot. I'm going to make people pass by it and ask me what it is whenever they come to my house. Oh, I'm going to be super braggy about it. And I'm not going to apologize. I know you are not. This just means the world to us. You know, we love this show. We love rewatching it. We love the community that has come here to do this journey with us. And we
非常令人兴奋。我超级兴奋。我非常兴奋。多亏了《办公室女郎》的粉丝们。我们赢得了iHeart电台的年度播客奖。年度播客奖，伙计们。年度大奖。非常感谢大家为我们投票。你们真的不知道我们对此有多兴奋。我们非常、非常自豪。我是说，女士，我们每周都把心血倾注在这个播客里。我们确实如此。我将珍视这个奖项，把它放在一个显眼的位置。每当有人来我家时，我都让他们从它旁边走过，问我那是什么。哦，我要为此大肆吹嘘一番。而且我不会道歉。我知道你不会的。这对我俩意义重大。你知道的，我们热爱这部剧。我们热爱重温它。我们热爱来到这里与我们一起踏上这段旅程的社群，我们
get to work with our best friend. You guys, it's such a blessing. I am so thankful. I have such gratitude. I already know where I'm putting mine. I'm putting mine right between my tight-ass Dundee Award and my She's Kind of a Bitch Award. Those are my two Dundee's and it's going right in between them. Well, you're going to trip over mine when you walk through my door. That's where mine's going. It's going on the floor. No. Right in front of my door so that everyone has to say what's that as they walk into my house. So there you go. It's going to be a really weird spot. Thank you guys so much. It really means a lot. Yeah. Thank you. All right. We'll take a break and we'll be back in just a moment. Okay. So we are back and this scene starts with Michael walking in and he just
还能和我们最好的朋友一起工作。伙计们，这真是太大的福气了。我太感激了。我充满了感恩。我已经知道我要把我的奖杯放在哪里了。我要把它放在我那个自以为是的邓迪奖和我那个“她有点像个碧池”奖之间。那是我的两个邓迪奖，它就要正正方方地放在它们中间。好吧，你走过我的门时会绊倒在我的奖杯上。那就是我要放它的地方。它要放在地板上。不。就在我的门前，这样每个人走进我家时都不得不问“那是什么”。所以就是这样。那会是一个非常奇怪的位置。非常感谢大家。这真的意义重大。是的。谢谢你们。好啦。我们休息一下，一会儿就回来。好的。我们回来了，这一场景从迈克尔走进来开始，他直接
throws his coat on Pam. And I know it's what you're all here for, but at one second, there's a fantastic shot of the plant at front reception. Tell us all about it. Okay. It's got an orange pot and I'm very curious what kind of plant this is. It's got very skinny stems and then kind of wispy, floofy leaves. What kind of plant is that? My plant people hit me up. I want to know. Well, when I spoke with Steve, our set decorator, he told me that most of the plants that he put at reception were of the vine variety because they did not flower and they stayed pretty consistent for a whole week. Well, I am familiar with the vine plants and I don't know what this one is. So our Beasley Botanical experts out there hit me up. Let me know what kind of plant that is.
把外套扔在了潘身上。我知道这是你们所有人来看这集的原因，但就在一秒钟，前台的植物有一个精彩的特写。给我们讲讲这是怎么回事吧。好的。它有一个橙色的花盆，我很好奇这是什么植物。它有非常细的茎，然后是那种纤细、毛茸茸的叶子。这是什么植物？我的植物达人们联系我吧。我想知道。嗯，当我跟我们的布景设计师史蒂夫交谈时，他告诉我，他放在前台的大多数植物都是藤蔓类的，因为它们不开花，而且能在整整一周内保持相当一致的状态。好吧，我对藤蔓植物很熟悉，但我不知道这是哪一种。所以外面的比斯利植物专家们联系我吧。让我知道那是什么植物。
It's at one second. Thank you. Well, this whole cold open is very funny. We find out from Pam in a talking head that Michael has been watching the movie, The Devil Wears Prada, but he doesn't watch it all at once. He watches it in little clips. He's a big Meryl Streep fan. So he's clearly identified with her character and now he is treating Pam the way Meryl Streep treats her employees in the film. It cracks me up that he watches it in little clips because if you really look at the scene, you can tell because he clearly just sees the part where she goes, stay, give me a stick. So he'll just come out and sort of like just regurgitate what he just watched in like 10 seconds. Well, we had a fan question about this from Amy S. Louise M. Ellen P.
就在第一秒。谢谢。嗯，整个开场白非常搞笑。我们从潘的一个访谈中得知，迈克尔一直在看电影《穿普拉达的女王》，但他不是一次性看完的。他是分小片段看的。他是梅丽尔·斯特里普的超级粉丝。所以他显然认同了她的角色，现在他对待潘的方式就像电影中梅丽尔·斯特里普对待她的员工一样。他分小片段观看这一点让我笑死，因为如果你仔细看这个场景，你就能看出来，因为他显然只看到了她说的“留下来，给我拿根棍子”那部分。所以他会走出来，把刚刚在10秒钟内看的东西像倒带一样复述出来。嗯，我们有一个来自艾米·S、露丝·M、艾伦·P
and Hannah C. Was John Krasinski with Emily Blunt yet when Michael does these references to The Devil Wears Prada or was it just a coincidence? It was a coincidence, you guys. I watched this with my daughter and Isabelle said, Mom, Devil Wears Prada. Isn't that John's wife? Yeah. Well, listen, this is not the only coincidence and it brings up a very interesting set of trivia that I have called six degrees of Devil Wears Prada. Oh, I am in it. Let's hear it. The office cast has a lot of connections to the cast of The Devil Wears Prada. Do you want to hear them? Yes, because I can only think of two. Okay, go. All right. Well, we know that John Krasinski will marry Emily Blunt. Steve Carell will go on after this episode to star in Get Smart with Anne
和汉娜·C的粉丝提问。当迈克尔引用《穿普拉达的女王》时，约翰·卡拉辛斯基已经和艾米莉·布朗特在一起了吗？还是这纯粹是个巧合？这纯粹是个巧合，伙计们。我和我女儿一起看这一集时，伊莎贝尔说：“妈妈，《穿普拉达的女王》。那不是约翰的妻子吗？”是的。好吧，听着，这并不是唯一的巧合，它引出了一套非常有趣的冷知识，我称之为《穿普拉达的女王》的六度分隔。哦，我参与其中了。说来听听。办公室剧组和《穿普拉达的女王》剧组有很多联系。你想听听吗？想，因为我只能想到两个。好吧，你说。好吧。嗯，我们知道约翰·卡拉辛斯基将迎娶艾米莉·布朗特。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在这集之后将与安妮·海瑟薇
Hathaway. Ah, Rainn Wilson was in Entourage with Adrian Grenier. Oh, that's a good one. Rich Summer, who was also in Devil Wears Prada, will later appear on the office as Pam's art school friend. And listen to this one. The movie The Devil Wears Prada was based on a book written by Lauren Weisberger and she's from Scranton. Yeah. Angela, you and I will eventually fake laugh at an award show with Meryl Streep. We will. I feel like that counts. She will have no idea and does not remember that moment, but we did walk up to her fake laughing. And finally, this one's a little bit of a stretch, but Stanley Tucci will marry Emily Blunt's sister in real life. That's the other one I was thinking of. I love that, by the way, that that's a stretch, but us laughing adjacent to Meryl Streep is not
一同主演《糊涂侦探》。啊，雷恩·威尔逊曾与阿德里安·格林尼尔一起出演《明星伙伴》。哦，这个好。里奇·萨默也出演过《穿普拉达的女王》，后来作为潘的艺术学校朋友出现在《办公室》里。听听这个。电影《穿普拉达的女王》改编自劳伦·韦丝伯格写的一本书，她来自斯克兰顿。是的。安吉拉，你和我最终会在颁奖典礼上和梅丽尔·斯特里普假笑。我们会这样的。我觉得这算数。她完全不知道，也不记得那一刻，但我们确实走过去对她假笑了。最后，这个有点勉强，但斯坦利·图齐在现实生活中将娶艾米莉·布朗特的姐姐。这是我能想到的另一个。顺便说一句，我喜欢这一点，这虽然有点勉强，但我们在梅丽尔·斯特里普旁边笑却不算
a stretch. Okay, I want you guys to know, though, a few months ago, this video went viral of Stanley Tucci making a cocktail. It is fantastic. I highly recommend you watch it start to finish. He just seems really cool. It's like, I want to hang out with Stanley Tucci in his kitchen. Yes, I want to sit on a stool in his kitchen while he makes me a cocktail. Yes, everyone does. Stanley Tucci, you heard that. So you're going to have two uninvited guests at some point. We'll be over soon. So this cold open ends with a Pam talking head that is really funny. And Jenna, I want you to check out the bloopers because you and Paul Lieberstein, you can hear him laughing off camera. The two of you could not get through this talking head about million dollar baby. You
勉强。好吧，不过我想让你们知道，几个月前，这个斯坦利·图齐制作鸡尾酒的视频疯传了。太棒了。我强烈建议你们从头到尾看一遍。他看起来真的很酷。就像，我想和斯坦利·图齐一起待在他的厨房里。是的，我想坐在他厨房的高脚凳上，看着他给我做鸡尾酒。是的，每个人都想。斯坦利·图齐，你听到了。所以你以后会有两个不速之客。我们很快就会过去。所以这个开场白在一个非常搞笑的潘的访谈中结束。珍娜，我想让你去看看NG花絮，因为你和保罗·利伯斯坦，你能听到他在镜头外笑。你们俩根本无法拍完这个关于《百万美元宝贝》的访谈。你们
kept cracking up. Yes, when Pam has to realize that Michael is going to kill her, we couldn't get through it. We couldn't get through it. I couldn't hold it long enough afterwards without laughing. Well, it's hilarious. And there's fun bloopers. You can check it out. Well, this episode opens with Michael and Jan. Jan's in another Juicy Couture track suit. And it's all she wears now. It's all she wears now. And yeah, absolutely. And they're picking out fabric for the condo. They're doing some redecorating. Yeah, there's a whole runner in deleted scenes where she comes in with this box of all this sort of fabric and curtain and all this kind of like samples. And Michael is just avoiding going into his office to talk to her. He like starts talking to Phyllis out of
一直笑场。是的，当潘意识到迈克尔要杀她时，我们根本拍不下去。我们拍不下去。我笑完之后根本憋不了那么久不笑。嗯，太搞笑了。而且有很好玩的NG花絮。你可以去看看。好吧，这一集以迈克尔和简的登场开场。简穿着另一套橘滋（Juicy Couture）运动服。她现在只穿这个了。她现在只穿这个了。是的，绝对的。他们在为公寓挑选面料。他们在做一些重新装修。是的，在删减片段里有一个完整的支线，她拿着这个装着所有这种面料、窗帘和各种样品的盒子走进来。而迈克尔只是在躲着不进办公室去跟她谈话。他突然开始跟菲利斯搭话
nowhere and Stanley and they're like, what are you doing? Jan's waiting for you. Well, he has a talking head where he explains why he might be avoiding things because money is really tight. Jan is insisting that they spend all this money redecorating the condo. But you know, at the end of his life, when he's sitting on his yacht, he's not going to be thinking about money. He's going to be thinking about how many friends he has and his children and his comedy albums. And by the way, he has a yacht. So he probably did pretty well money wise. I thought that was so funny. Well, Jenna, as I remember, you have some very strong feelings on yachts and yacht ownership. I do. I don't get it. There was this time when I felt like every time I opened Instagram,
莫名其妙的还有斯坦利，他们就问：“你在干嘛？简在等你呢。”嗯，他有一个访谈，在其中解释了他为什么要躲避事情，因为手头真的很紧。简坚持要花所有的钱重新装修公寓。但你知道的，在他生命的尽头，当他坐在游艇上时，他不会去想钱的事。他会去想他有多少朋友、他的孩子们以及他的喜剧专辑。顺便说一句，他有一艘游艇。所以他经济上可能过得相当不错。我觉得这太搞笑了。嗯，珍娜，我记得你对游艇和游艇所有权有非常强烈的看法。我有。我不理解。有一段时间，我感觉每次打开Instagram，
every celebrity was like yachting. They were getting on a yacht and I was like, what is this world? I don't get it. This yachting vacation world. You're cooped up in a small space on water. I have to imagine you get seasick. And there's a crew right on top of you. Like, I like privacy when I'm on vacation. I don't... I mean, listen, that's a whole other thing that I have. And I think it's because I spent so much time in the service industry being a caterer or whatever. People don't see you when you're a caterer or something, when you're bringing them the drinks and the hors d'oeuvres. But News Flash, we can actually hear you and see you and everything you're doing. And I can't tell you how many fancy Hollywood parties I catered. I observed so much
每个名人都在玩游艇。他们都在上游艇，我就想：“这算什么世界？我不理解。”这种游艇度假的世界。你被困在水上一个狭小的空间里。我想你一定会晕船的。而且船员就在你头顶上。就像，我度假时喜欢隐私。我……我是说，听着，那是我的另一套理论。我想这是因为我在服务行业花了太多时间，当过餐饮服务员什么的。当你当餐饮服务员或者端酒水和小吃时，人们根本注意不到你。但重大新闻，我们其实能听到你、看到你以及你所做的一切。我无法告诉你我曾为多少个奢华的好莱坞派对提供过餐饮服务。我观察到了太多的
stuff. People just act like you're invisible. I wouldn't be able to relax on a yacht. I wouldn't be able to relax because I would know that they're watching me. They're listening. I love yachting. How do these celebrities behave this way on yachts? How are they relaxed? I love it. I don't get it. You're pivot about yachting. I thought we're going to talk about how it seems wasteful to spend that much money on a boat, but you're like, but also, they're watching you. They're watching you. No, it is also, I don't get that part. But ultimately, I think what it is is that I like cities and museums, and I like walking on my vacations. I'm not like a sit on a boat and take selfies person. That's not for me. I love a boat. I love the ocean. I love getting
事情。人们表现得就像你是隐形的一样。我在游艇上根本无法放松。我无法放松，因为我知道他们在看着我。他们在听着。我喜欢游艇。这些名人怎么能在游艇上表现得这样？他们怎么放松得下来？我喜欢它。我不理解。你对游艇的态度急转直下。我以为我们要谈谈花那么多钱买艘船有多浪费，但你的意思是，但同时，他们在看着你。他们在看着你。不，这也是一部分，我不理解那部分。但归根结底，我觉得原因是我喜欢城市和博物馆，我喜欢在度假时走路。我不是那种坐在船上自拍的人。那不适合我。我喜欢船。我喜欢海洋。我喜欢出海，但我不需要在船上度假。
out on the ocean, but I don't need a vacation in the boat. Do you know what I mean? I like to be on land, but then take the boat places like adventures. Yes, you would want to go diving or snorkeling, but then return to land for the sleeping part. Yes, and the hanging out part and the eating and all that. Yeah. Well, we're not yachters. You know what you're not going to hear on Office Ladies? An ad for yachting. You know what else you're not going to hear? Oh my God, I was on the most fabulous yacht. Oh my God, cut to two years from now when like we're yachting. And we're on a yacht. That's what happens in the universe. You put something out there and you're like, I would never. And then all of a sudden the universe is like jokes on you. You're a
你知道我的意思吗？我喜欢在陆地上，然后把船开到别的地方，比如去探险。是的，你会想去潜水或浮潜，但睡觉时要回到陆地上。是的，还有闲逛、吃饭以及所有这些。嗯，我们不是游艇爱好者。你知道你在《办公室女郎》里听不到什么吗？游艇广告。你知道你还听不到什么吗？哦，天哪，我坐过了最豪华的游艇。哦，天哪，切到两年后，仿佛我们在玩游艇。我们在游艇上。宇宙就是这样运转的。你嘴上说着我绝不，然后突然宇宙就开玩笑说：“捉弄你吧。你是个游艇爱好者。”我们被邀请去参观制造游艇的工厂。我们很喜欢。他们带我们出海玩了一趟。然后我们在游艇上自拍。听说，我很乐意去参观游艇工厂。
yotter. We get invited to tour the factory where they make yachts. And we love them. And they take us out on one. And then we take a selfie on a yacht. Listen, I would love a yacht factory tour. I know, I would too. So now we're at Jim and Dwight's despot and Jim overhears Dwight taking what sounds like a reservation for a bed and breakfast. And Jim's like, what? What? What's happening? It's so funny. Jim is clearly on hold with someone or has just made a call and he hangs up so he can better focus on Dwight's phone call. Yeah, it's really good. And for our background catchers, there is a great shot of Dwight's computer screen. And it just looks like a paper order. So way to go props. You can't see what rain was actually surfing on the internet.
我知道，我也想。所以现在我们来到了吉姆和德怀特的办公室，吉姆无意中听到德怀特接听一个听起来像是住宿加早餐旅馆的预订电话。吉姆就想：什么？什么？发生什么了？太搞笑了。吉姆显然在和某人保持通话或者刚打完电话，他挂断了电话，以便能更好地专注听德怀特的电话。是的，真的很棒。对于我们的背景搜寻者来说，有一个德怀特电脑屏幕的精彩特写。那看起来只是一张纸质订单。所以道具组干得漂亮。你看不到雷恩实际上在互联网上浏览什么。我在三分钟三十秒时在背景前台还有几个其他的背景捕捉。我在向我们的摄像师兰德尔微笑。哦，我没意识到我们已经开机了。
I have a couple of other background catches here at three minutes, 30 seconds in the background at reception. I am smiling at Randall, our camera operator. Oh, I didn't realize we had started rolling. Oh, that's so cute. You can see me share a moment with Randall and then quickly get into character. Also in the background on Creed's computer, he is playing an epic game of Solitaire. That sounds about right. Well, Dwight has this talking head about agrotourism. And it's more than just a B&B. It's about people visiting a farm and you give them a bed. And it's like a whole experience. And Pam calls to sort of make a fake reservation, but ends up like booking a trip to Shroop Farms. Yeah. It's going to be Jim and Pam's first night away together.
哦，太可爱了。你可以看到我和兰德尔分享了一个时刻，然后迅速进入角色。同样在背景中克里德的电脑上，他正在玩一局史诗级的纸牌接龙。这听起来很符合他的风格。嗯，德怀特关于生态旅游有这样一段访谈。这不仅仅是一家B&B。这是关于人们参观农场，你给他们一张床。这就像是一种完整的体验。而潘打电话假装预订，结果却像是预订了一次什鲁特农场的旅行。是的。这将是吉姆和潘在一起的第一个不回家的夜晚。好的。我喜欢这样。实际上，我觉得这超级甜蜜。嗯，这绝对是一个他们永远不会忘记的周末。迈克尔有一个访谈，解释说他们以前有两辆车，但他们把它们换掉了。现在他们只有一辆新车，是给简买的保时捷。
Okay. I love that. Actually, I think that's super sweet. Well, it's definitely like a weekend they'll never forget. Michael has a talking head where explains they used to have two cars, but they traded them in. Now they just have one and the new car is a Porsche for Jan. Yeah. I mean, Jan is just dismantling his whole life. And when he says, I need the car tonight, she's like, for your improv, can't you just improv driving there or take the bus? Like, she doesn't even know where he's going or what he's doing. She has no idea the big hole financially that she's creating and how he is scrambling. Yeah. I know. It's very sad. It made me sad. Well, we had a fan catch here from Matthew L Colby Shannon, Joseph Stevens, Catherine A.
是的。我是说，简正在拆散他的整个生活。当他说“我今晚需要用车”时，她说：“为了你的即兴表演？难道你就不能即兴假装开车去或者坐公交车吗？”就像，她甚至不知道他要去哪儿，在做什么。她根本不知道她正在制造巨大的财务黑洞，而他正在苦苦挣扎。是的。我知道。这太令人难过了。这让我很难过。嗯，我们这里有一个来自马修·L、科尔比·尚农、约瑟夫·史蒂文斯、凯瑟琳·A和麦肯纳·H的粉丝搜寻。在其他人当中，他们说迈克尔提到他们把两辆车都换掉来给简买了一辆保时捷，但迈克尔的赛百灵（Sebring）不是公司的租赁车吗？他怎么能把它换掉呢？好问题。
and McKenna H. Among others who said Michael says that they traded in both of their cars to buy a Porsche for Jan, but wasn't Michael Sebring a company lease? How would he have traded it in? Good catch. Maybe if you don't take the company car, you get some sort of cash credit and he used that for the Porsche. That sounds like a good theory. Do we like that? I made that up just now. I like it very much. Okay. Well, now, lady, we've got this great scene of you and Dwight in the parking lot. You're getting some of your belongings back. Yes. Dwight gives Angela her cardigan, her sleeping cardigan, her sleep apnea mask, and then Angela asks, well, where's my chair figurine? And Dwight says, I don't know what you're
也许如果你不选择公司用车，你会得到某种现金抵免，他把那个用在了保时捷上。这听起来是个不错的理论。我们喜欢这样吗？我刚才现编的。我很喜欢。好吧。好吧，女士，我们现在看到了这个精彩的场景，你和德怀特在停车场。你拿回了一些你的随身物品。是的。德怀特把安吉拉的开衫、她的睡眠开衫、她的睡眠呼吸暂停面罩还给了她，然后安吉拉问道：“嗯，我的椅子雕像呢？”德怀特说：“我不知道你在说什么。你没把它留在那儿。我到处找过了。我已经把你的记忆从房间里擦洗干净了。”她就说：“哼，好吧。”嗯，我对这些物品有几个疑问。例如，睡眠开衫。是的。这真的是个东西吗？让我告诉你，因为我谷歌了一下。
talking about. You didn't leave it there. I've looked all over. I've scrubbed the room of your memory. And she's like, huh, fine. Well, I had a few questions about these items. For example, the sleeping cardigan. Yeah. Is it a thing? Let me tell you, because I Googled it. It is. So if you type in sleeping cardigan on Google, one of the first things that comes up is a sleep sweater from Target. What? How do you not already know about this? I don't know. Target expert. I know. It said sleeping sweaters. You can get them at Target. Sleeping sweaters. Well, I shot a movie in Detroit. It was the movie that I fell in love with Lee, Giant Mechanical Man. And it was very cold. And we were staying in this hotel,
是的。所以如果你在谷歌上输入“睡眠开衫”，最先弹出的结果之一就是塔吉特（Target）百货的一款睡眠毛衣。什么？你怎么会不知道这个？我不知道。塔吉特专家。我知道。上面写着睡眠毛衣。你可以在塔吉特买到。睡眠毛衣。嗯，我在底特律拍过一部电影。那是我爱上李的那部电影，机械人吉姆。而且天气非常冷。我们住在一家酒店里，我怎么也暖和不起来。我穿着毛衣睡觉，还戴着帽子。我睡觉时完全是穿戴整齐的。哦，我睡觉时穿着大概三层衣服。而乔什只穿着内裤。嗯，太荒谬了。你显然需要一件来自塔吉特的睡眠开衫。我想我需要一件塔吉特所谓的睡眠毛衣。然后安吉拉还拿回了她的睡眠呼吸暂停面罩。
and I could not get warm. And I wore a sweater to bed and a hat. I was like fully dressed when I went to sleep. Oh, I go to sleep with like three layers on. And Josh is in like his undies. Well, it's ridiculous. You clearly need a sleeping cardigan from Target. I guess I need a sleep sweater is what Target calls it. And then Angela also gets her sleep apnea mask back. Do we find out that Angela has sleep apnea? I mean, this is a serious sleep disorder. Well, we got a fan question from Rachel Nielsen about that. She was very surprised when Dwight handed Angela the CPAP machine. She said, as someone who used to work in the sleep disorder industry, this was very interesting to me because Angela does not fit the typical
我们发现安吉拉有睡眠呼吸暂停吗？我是说，这是一个严重的睡眠障碍。嗯，我们收到了雷切尔·尼尔森关于此事的粉丝提问。当德怀特把CPAP（持续气道正压通气）机器递给安吉拉时，她非常惊讶。她说，作为一个曾在睡眠障碍行业工作过的人，这对我非常有趣，因为安吉拉并不符合典型的CPAP用户特征。我本以为是德怀特在用。对于安吉拉，当时有什么处理过程或背景故事吗？还是这完全是个惊喜？对我来说没有背景故事。我想这让编剧室觉得好笑，于是它就被写进剧本里了。嗯，现在知道安吉拉有一段时间没有用她的睡眠呼吸暂停机器了，我为她感到非常担心。我知道。这让我感到焦虑。我不喜欢去想人们在任何一段时间里缺乏他们需要的必要工具或药物。
CPAP profile. I would have thought Dwight used it. Was there any thought processor backstory for Angela on this? Or was this a total surprise? And no backstory for me. I think this made the writer's room chuckle and it went in the script. Well, I feel very worried for Angela knowing now that she hasn't had her sleep apnea machine for a while. I know. This caused me to feel anxious. I don't like thinking that people are without the necessary tools or medicines that they need for any period of time. You know what really bothers me? What? It really bothers me if I'm watching a movie and someone gets even a minor injury and they don't deal with it immediately. It really, I get, I'm very distracted by it. I know. Like someone gets a cut and they don't
你知道什么真让我烦心吗？什么？如果我在看电影时有人受了哪怕是轻微的伤，而他们没有立即处理，这真的让我很分心。我知道。就像有人受了割伤，而他们没有好好包扎。这在动作片里经常发生，真的让我很烦恼。但真正让我烦心的是，在有人受伤后，反派按压伤口。你知道的，就像有人肩膀中了枪，然后当他们被反派审问时，反派按压他们的伤口。我受不了。这让我起鸡皮疙瘩，我根本无法接受。嗯，千万不要看那种把人丢在荒郊野岭让他们只能自生自灭的节目，因为他们会受伤，然后不得不试图自己包扎。不。如果情况真的很糟糕，他们会派一个医疗兵进去，但必须情况真的很糟，医疗兵才会介入。
like wrap it up right. It happens a lot in action films and it really bugs me. But what really bothers me is after someone gets an injury when the villain presses on the injury. You know, like someone gets like a bullet to the shoulder and then when they're being interrogated by the villain, the villain presses on their wound. I can't. It's the heebie-jeebies for me and I can't deal with it. Well, do not watch the show alone where they drop people off in the middle of nowhere and they have to just survive because they get injured and they have to try to patch it up on their own. No. If it gets really bad, they send a medic in, but it's got to get bad for the medic to like chop her in. No. You couldn't do it. See, I can't. I couldn't do it. And then you, you know, of course, you're constantly
不。你做不到。你看，我做不到。我做不到。不。嗯，清单上的最后一件事，当然是椅子雕像。我想让你们知道，我有一个。你有剧里那个吗？没有。不，这对我太搞笑了。我曾把它作为礼物收到过。我甚至不知道是什么时候，比如高中时，从某个地方，比如布伦达阿姨，是你送给我的吗？不管怎样，我有一个小椅子雕像，它跟着我去了大学，坐在我的窗台上，它一路辗转来到了加州，它在我的梳妆台上，和卧室里的梳妆台放在一起，我得去看看它是否还在那儿，因为在某个时候，伊莎贝尔觉得它很可爱，然后伊莎贝尔会，就像，我觉得把它放进她的房间里了。我在试图追踪它的下落，伙计们。
seeing like their banged up thumb as they try to fish. Yeah, this is what I'm saying. I can't. You can't do it. You can't do it. No. Well, the last thing on the list, of course, is the chair of figurine. And I want you guys to know, I own one. Do you have the one from the show? No. No, it's so funny to me. I was given one as a gift. I don't know when even like in high school from like, I don't know, Aunt Brenda, did you give it to me? Anyway, I have a little chair figurine and it went with me to college and sat on my windowsill and it made its way all the way to California and it was on my dresser with like my dresser in the bedroom and I need to go see if it's still there because at some point, Isabel thought it was cute and then Isabel would like,
不管怎样，这是一个冗长无聊的故事，用来告诉你现实生活中我有一个椅子雕像。此外，在六分二十四秒的场景中，安吉拉，你穿着非常高的高跟鞋。为什么？这么高。哦，可能是因为我必须站在雷恩旁边，因为通常我在和他的对手戏中，他是坐着的。如果我必须站在他旁边，他身高六尺三（约1米9），我身高五尺一（约1米55），大高跟鞋就得派上用场了。嗯，这些鞋子太夸张了，伙计们。去看看吧。六分二十四秒。而且如果你切回六分零九秒，有一个我的猫毛发夹的精彩特写，那是做我发型的金·费里（Kim Ferry）用胶枪自己做的。多年以后，她把它放在一个阴影盒里送给了我，我还有我的猫毛发夹。哦，我懂。
like I think put it in her room. I'm trying to track it down guys. Anyway, long boring story to tell you in real life, I have a chair figurine. Also at six minutes and 24 seconds in the scene, Angela, you are wearing very high heels. Why? So high. Oh, probably because I had to stand next to rain because normally in my scenes with him, he's seated. And if I have to stand next to him, he's six, three, I am five, one, you get the big heels get brought out. Well, these were massive guys. Check it out. Six minutes, 24 seconds. And also if you toggle back to six minutes, nine seconds, there's a great shot of my cat hair clip that Kim Ferry, who did my hair, made herself with like a glue gun. And years later, she gave it to me in a shadow box and I
所以现在我们要转到凯文向员工区发表重大公告的场景，他非常希望他们能来看他的乐队。那是一个乐队对决之夜。将有一个掌声测量仪，而他只能靠掌声取胜。他希望大家都能来为他的乐队——斯克兰顿城（Scranton City）——鼓掌，等等，不是斯克兰顿城，他已经不再是其中一员了。显然有些我们不知道的过节。但他邀请了整个办公室的人务必前来。嗯，我们收到了关于这个情节的粉丝提问。好吧。来自娜奥米·Y、贝特丽丝·W、M·雷恩、艾莉森·奎格利和伊丽莎白·韦伯。他们说，为什么潘不去看凯文的乐队？没有人去看她的艺术展，她感到非常受伤。
have my cat hair clips. Oh, I know. So now we're going to move on to the scene where Kevin makes a big announcement to the bullpen that he would really love them to come see his band. It's like a battle of the band's night. And there's going to be an applause meter and he will only win by clapping. And he wants everyone to come and clap for his band, Scranton City to not Scranton City, which he is no longer a part of. There is clearly some bad blood that we don't know about. But he invites he invites the whole office to please come. Well, we had a fan question about this. Okay. From Naomi Y Beatrice W M Reigns, Allison Quigley, and Elizabeth Shannon. They said, why didn't Pam go see Kevin's band? No one came to her art show and she felt so hurt.
难道她不想去看凯文，好让他不至于像她那样感到不受支持吗？哇，这真的是个很好的切入点。是的。我是这么想的，伙计们。我在想，也许她去看过他的乐队。也许她去看过斯克兰顿城。也许办公室里的每个人都去看过了。而这就像是来看乐队的又一个请求。你知道那种人，他们在即兴乐队里或者他们说单口喜剧。然后你会说，老兄，我已经看过你七场单口喜剧秀了。就像我今晚不能来看这一场了。我真的去不了。也许这就是正在发生的事情。我想我就是那种人，因为我一直在参加即兴喜剧秀。我总是说：“嘿，来看我的即兴秀吧。”而人们会说：“你过去三个星期里每周表演三次……”
Wouldn't she want to see Kevin so he wouldn't feel unsupported the way she did? Wow, that's a really good call. Yeah. Here's what I'm thinking, guys. I'm thinking maybe she has gone to see his band. Maybe she went to go see Scranton City. Maybe everyone in the office has gone to see it. And this is like another request to come see the band. You know those people, like they're in the pand or they do stand up. And you're like, dude, I've seen seven of your stand up shows. Like I can't come to this one tonight. I just can't do it. Maybe that's what's happening. I think I was this person because I was always in an improv show. I was always like, hey, catch my improv show. And people are like, you perform three times a week for like the last
她难道不想去看看凯文，免得他像她当年那样觉得孤立无援吗？哇，这个猜测真的很准。对啊。伙计们，我是这么想的。我在想，也许她是去看他的乐队了。也许她去看了斯克兰顿城乐队。也许办公室里的所有人都去看演出 了。这就像是又一次邀请大家去看乐队演出。你知道那种人，他们要么在乐队里，要么做单口喜剧。然后你会想，老兄，你的单口喜剧我已经看过七场了。今晚这场我实在去不了。我真的去不了。也许这就是正在发生的事。我觉得我以前就是这种人，因为我总是有即兴表演。我总是说，嘿，来看我的即兴表演吧。然后大家就会想，你过去大概每周都演三次，连续
four years. I can't come see you do improv anymore. Stop asking me. I can relate to because I did all that stuff too. And I know that especially with stand up, like at least at the level that I was performing guys, I didn't do stand up. I did this really weird comedic magic show. I won't go down that rabbit hole now. What? What? I did. It was like I was a silent comedic magician. What? And I performed to music and comedy clubs. Jenna, this is so amazing. I cannot believe I didn't know this about you. We've been friends for so long. You were like a comedic mime? Yeah. What? I would give anything to see that. Anything. I did magic tricks using my hands. And they weren't really magic. It was a joke, but I performed it as if I was a great magician. So it
四年了。我不能再去看你表演即兴喜剧了。别再问我了。我能感同身受，因为我也做过所有那些事情。我知道，特别是单口喜剧，至少在我表演的那个水平上，伙计们，我没做过单口。我做的是那种非常奇怪的喜剧魔术秀。我现在就不扯远了。什么？什么？我做过。就好像我是一个无声的喜剧魔术师。什么？我在音乐会和喜剧俱乐部表演。珍娜，这太惊人了。我真不敢相信我不知道你这事儿。我们做了这么久的朋友。你就像是个喜剧哑剧演员？ yeah。什么？我愿意付出一切去看那个。真的，一切。我用手变魔术。而且那其实不算魔术。是个笑话，但我的表演方式就好像我是个伟大的魔术师。所以它
was like a like an ironic kind of like. And you did it to music. To music. And did you speak? No. No, there was no speaking. Oh, lady. Yeah. I need a photo. I need a video. I need something. Okay. I need it in my life. I'll do the show for you sometime. This was my only foray into what? Promise me we will have wine together and you will do this for me. I'll do it. I still have my tuxedo and. Shut up. Yeah, I still have it. You wore a tuxedo. Yes. I was a fancy magician. I wore coat and tails. Oh my God. Yeah. So listen, my point is I don't know how to come back from that. I don't know. It's going to take me a beat. Okay. Well, listen, what I'm saying in relation to Scranton City 2 is in my experience performing this show, the number of people you brought in
有点像那种讽刺式的。而且你是配合音乐表演的。伴着音乐。你会说话吗？不。不，没有说话。哦，天哪。Yeah。我需要一张照片。我需要一个视频。我需要点什么。好吧。我的生活中需要它。我改天为你表演这个秀。这是我唯一的尝试，什么？答应我，我们一起喝红酒，你要为我表演这个。我会的。我还有我的燕尾服，还有。闭嘴。Yeah，我还有它。你穿了燕尾服。是的。我是一个高档魔术师。我穿着燕尾服。哦，天哪。Yeah。所以听着，我的重点是我不知道该怎么接着这个话题了。我不知道。我得缓一下。好吧。嗯，听着，我关于“斯克兰顿之城2”的看法是，根据我表演这个节目的经验，你带过来的人数
who bought a ticket to like the comedy show that night, that determined your placement in the show. So like if no one came, you'd be at the end of the night and you'd be performing to a room of like three people. Right. So, you know, this is why Kevin needs people to come, I think, because, well, he has the applause meter. I don't know. This is gone very off topic, everyone. I'm sorry. I, my heart is so full. I am, this is a gift I was not expecting today. I have all of these visuals in my head of you and a tuxedo miming magic tricks at a comedy club. It's, um, yeah. Oh, it's, it's just 100% awesome. Okay. Well, now Michael also says he cannot go to Kevin's show and Jim and Pam, they're like, oh, light bulb. This is when we tell them we should have dinner because they know
那天晚上买票来看喜剧秀的人，决定了你在节目中的出场顺序。所以如果没人来，你就会排在晚上最后表演，面对的观众可能只有三个人左右。对吧。所以，你知道，这就是为什么凯文需要大家来，我觉得，因为，嗯，他有掌声测量仪。我不知道。这话题扯得太远了，各位。我很抱歉。我，我的内心感慨万千。我，这是一个我今天意料之外的礼物。我的脑海里充满了各种画面：你穿着燕尾服在喜剧俱乐部里用哑剧变魔术。这，嗯，Yeah，这真是百分之百的棒。好吧。那么，现在迈克尔也说他不能去凯文的秀，吉姆和帕姆，他们就像是，哦，灯泡亮了。这就是我们告诉他们我们应该一起吃晚饭的时候，因为他们知道
he's not available. So sneaky you two. Yes. Also, very sweet to realize that if Michael was available, he probably would go to Kevin's show because that's Michael, right? Of course, he goes to everything. Yeah. And also, maybe now it's an opportunity to get away from Jan. Yeah. There's all this. There's a whole deleted scene runner where he's just avoiding having to talk to her. Well, the reason that Michael can't go to this show or have dinner with Jim and Pam is because he has taken a second job as a telemarketer to pay his bills. And Paul does this very beautiful thing, I think, in his directing. As Michael's riding the bus, getting off the bus stop, walking into this building, you hear this dialogue and it says, I'm sorry, Mr. O'Brien. I didn't mean to interrupt your dinner.
他没空。你们两个真狡猾。是的。同时，也很贴心地意识到，如果迈克尔有空，他可能就会去凯文的秀，因为那是迈克尔，对吧？当然，他什么都去。Yeah。而且，也许现在是个摆脱简的好机会。Yeah。这中间有好多。有一整段被删掉的剧情，他一直在躲避和她说话。嗯，迈克尔不能去看这个秀或者和吉姆和帕姆共进晚餐的原因是，他兼职做了一名电话推销员来付账单。保罗在执导时做了一件非常美妙的事情，我觉得。当迈克尔坐着公车，下公车站，走入这栋大楼时，你听到这段对话，里面说：“对不起，奥布赖恩先生。我不是故意打扰您的晚餐。
I just have a very exciting offer. My records indicate that you have expressed interest in losing some weight. Well, what if I told you that I have a pill that will make you 50 pounds lighter in five minutes? How does that sound? Amazing, right? And it's this wonderful way that we now, as an audience, know exactly what's happening. Yeah. Before we even see what's in the building, I thought it was so brilliant. Yeah. Yeah. That's some beautiful writing. Well, now also Pam and Jim are arriving to Shrewt Farms. Yeah, Pam is clearly in super pun mode. She's calling it the Beats Motel, the Embassy Beats, the Radish Inn. She's in rare form. Well, this scene of Jim and Pam driving up to Shrewt Farms, this is the scene where John turned
我只是有一个非常令人兴奋的优惠。我的记录显示，您曾表示有兴趣减掉一些体重。那么，如果我告诉您我有一种药丸，能让您在五分钟内轻五十磅呢？听起来怎么样？太棒了，对吧？这是我们作为一个观众，现在确切知道发生了什么的一种绝妙方式。Yeah。甚至在我们看到大楼里面有什么之前，我觉得这太绝了。Yeah。Yeah。这写得真好。好吧，现在帕姆和吉姆也到达了施鲁特农场。Yeah，帕姆显然进入了超级双关语模式。她把它叫做“甜菜汽车旅馆”（Beats Motel）、“大使馆甜菜”（Embassy Beats）、“萝卜客栈”（Radish Inn）。她状态奇佳。嗯，吉姆和帕姆开车去施鲁特农场的这场戏，就是约翰打开了
on the seat warmer on my side of the car. We talked about it when he came on Office Ladies. Yes, he called it his Clooney joke, right? Yes. Yes. I just kept getting so hot. I was like, John, I am so hot. Or you had, he's like, no, I don't know what you're talking about. And he had turned on my seat warmer. Oh my gosh, I love that. Because you couldn't have the AC on in the car. That was the thing because it messed with the sound. Right. So we had to have, you know, the car is getting warm. It was warm in the day. And then on top of it, your seat is heating up. That's so great. Well, I want you guys to know right as they turn down the road to go to Shrewt Farms, when this scene is happening,
我车那边的座椅加热器的这场戏。我们当他来《办公室女郎》时聊过这个。是的，他把它叫做他的“克鲁尼笑话”，对吧？是的。是的。我一直觉得好热。我就说，约翰，我好热啊。或者你，他就像是，不，我不知道你在说什么。而他却打开了我的座椅加热器。哦天哪，我太喜欢这个了。因为你不能在车里开空调。就是那回事，因为空调会干扰收音。对吧。所以我们不得不，你知道，车里变得暖和了。那天天气很热。然后最要命的是，你的座位还在加热。太棒了。嗯，我想让大家知道，就在他们拐入通往施鲁特农场的路时，当这场戏发生时，
there's a great shot of the Shrewt Farms mailbox. And many times that I filmed there with Rain, one time I took my camera and I took all of these kind of artsy photos and I took an artsy photo of the mailbox. But I love it. I actually think it'd be really cool. Like I should like blow it up like canvas size. I think it looks really cool. We had a fan question about this scene of Jim and Pam arriving at Shrewt Farms from Amaya Norsi. She said at around eight minutes, 21 seconds, Moe's appears behind their car and starts running alongside them. How was that decided? Because it's really funny and it creates Moe's personality. I reached out to Paul. I would love to hear what he says. Well, first of all, he came up with the idea for Moe's running
有一个施鲁特农场邮箱的精彩特写。我和雷恩在那里拍摄时有很多次，有一次我拿着相机拍了各种具有艺术感的照片，我拍了一张邮箱的艺术照。但我很喜欢它。我其实觉得它会很酷。就像我应该把它放大到画布那么大。我觉得它看起来真的很酷。我们有一个关于吉姆和帕姆到达施鲁特农场这场戏的粉丝提问，来自阿玛亚·诺尔西（Amaya Norsi）。她说在大约8分21秒时，莫斯（Moe's）出现在他们的车后面，开始跟在车旁跑步。这是怎么决定的？因为这真的很好笑，而且塑造了莫斯的性格。我联系了保罗。我很想听听他是怎么说的。嗯，首先，他在俄罗斯的一家咖啡馆里想出了让莫斯跟着车跑步的点子，
alongside the car while in a cafe in Russia. I love how it's like his inspiration is in Russia. It's hilarious. I love how he's always in these like foreign countries when he is writing these scripts and having his good ideas. But he said he started laughing out loud at the idea of Moe's running alongside the car, quote, like a dog. And that's what he wrote in the script. So that moment was totally scripted that Moe's would run alongside the car like a puppy dog to greet the new visitors. And it was written by an American tourist in Russia laughing out loud by himself to no one in a cafe in a cafe. Well, I wanted to commend Mike sure on how fast he is. I was so fast. Dang. And you guys, we filmed that several times. We filmed that arrival because we had to
就像一条狗一样。我喜欢他的灵感居然来自俄罗斯。这太搞笑了。我喜欢他写这些剧本、有好点子时总是在这种外国国家。但他说，他一想到莫斯像狗一样跟着车跑，就忍不住大声笑出来，引用原话：“就像一条狗。”这就是他在剧本里写的内容。所以那一刻完全是剧本里写好的，莫斯像小狗一样跟着车跑来迎接新访客。而且这个剧本是一个美国游客在俄罗斯的咖啡馆里，一个人自顾自地大声笑，旁边空无一人时写出来的。嗯，我要称赞迈克尔·舒尔（Mike Schur）跑得有多快。我当时跑得真快。天哪。而且伙计们，我们拍了好几次。我们拍摄了那个到达的镜头，因为我们必须
film it with a cameraman inside the car. But then we also have a shot of us driving where we took the cameraman out of the car. And they just shot John and I. So I mean, Mike ran a lot that day. Well, I think Mike was put through the wringer in this episode. There is a whole deleted scene where he is jumping on a kind of busted trampoline for Pam and Jim and doing all of these things. Helicopter, look over here. And he's doing like constantly he was on that trampoline doing tons of stuff. He must have been so sore after this day hot and tired. Yeah. Well, lady, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to meet Nick Figaro, manager to the stars. And also take a look inside shrewd farms. I like it. All right, I'm going to take a break and I will
用一个摄影师在车里拍摄。但我们也有一个我们开车的镜头，我们把摄影师从车里拿出来了。他们只拍了我和约翰。所以我是说，迈克·舒尔那天跑了很多次。嗯，我觉得迈克在这个集里可受了不少折磨。有一个被删掉的完整场景，他在为帕姆和吉姆在一个有点破烂的蹦床上跳跃，做各种各样的事情。直升机，看这里。他一直在那个蹦床上做成吨的事情。这天过後他一定酸痛极了，又热又累。Yeah。嗯，女士们，我们为什么不休息一下？当我们回来时，我们将见到明星经纪人尼克·菲加罗（Nick Figaro）。还要看看施鲁特农场的内部。我喜欢。好的，我要去休息一下，我
not be on a yacht, but I might be doing some magic. So now we are back. Michael is in his cubicle at the telemarketing company. And his boss, Nick Figaro notices the camera crew. He walks over. He's like, what's happening here? Michael's like, it's okay. They're with me. And then he has this very funny speech where he's like, we're a legitimate operation. Like clearly they're not because he really not. He has to like point that out. Well, the actor who plays Nick Figaro is Alan Wasserman. And here are some other roles that he has played. He's done a ton of television shows. But I also found it interesting that he played the gym teacher in the Tom Hanks movie Big and the job interviewer in the Tom Cruise movie Cocktails. Oh, wow. Oh, those are two great
不会在一艘游艇上，但我可能会变几个魔术。现在我们回来了。迈克尔在电话推销公司的隔间里。他的老板尼克·菲加罗注意到了摄像团队。他走了过来。他说，这里发生什么事？迈克尔说，没关系。他们是跟我一起的。然后他发表了一段非常搞笑的演讲，他说，我们是一个合法的运作。就像显然他们不是，因为他真的不是。他不得不指出这一点。嗯，扮演尼克·菲加罗的演员是艾伦·沃瑟曼（Alan Wasserman）。以下是他扮演过的一些其他角色。他演过成吨的电视剧。但我也觉得有趣的是，他在汤姆·汉克斯的电影《飞越未来》（Big）中扮演了健身教练，在汤姆·克鲁斯的电影《鸡尾酒》（Cocktails）中扮演了工作面试官。哦，哇。哦，那是两部伟大的
movies. Well, my favorite thing is when he does what Michael always does, he calls a conference room meeting. Five minutes. Yes. Oh, these things are useless. Yes. And then in this conference room meeting, when Nick Figaro is trying to explain how to make a sale, Michael is just making jokes under his breath. Yes. And his coworkers love him. He's the gym of the telemarketing office. He is. And they just want him to hang out with him. They're constantly inviting him to go hang out. There's deleted scenes where they they are just they hang on his every word. Well, I got very interested in this scene at 10 minutes, 25 seconds. There is a couple. Did you see them? The woman is pregnant, very pregnant. And this man, they're all over each other,
电影。嗯，我最喜欢的是当他做迈克尔总是做的事情时，他召开了一个会议室会议。五分钟。是的。哦，这些东西毫无用处。是的。然后在这个会议室会议上，当尼克·菲加罗试图解释如何做成一笔销售时，迈克尔只是在低声说笑话。是的。他的同事们都喜欢他。他是电话推销办公室里的吉姆。他就是。他们只是想和他一起混。他们经常邀请他去玩。有被删掉的场景，他们，他们对他的每一句话言听计从。嗯，我对10分25秒的这个场景非常感兴趣。有一对夫妇。你看到了吗？那个女人怀孕了，非常显怀。而这个男人，他们黏在一起，
very lovey-dovey, right? And they are in all the other deleted scenes, too. They're always sort of like in some kind of embrace. I became a little bit obsessed with them. I was like, is this woman really pregnant? Were they hired as a couple? What is the story here? So I did a bit of a deep dive. Okay. I found out that the woman is an actress named Anne Maddox. And then I found out that Anne Maddox is our producer Cody's friend. What? They're friends on Instagram. I deep dived. I was like, how can I get an in with this woman, Anne? So Cody reached out to her friend and she answered all my questions. Oh, give me all of it. I want it. Give it to me. Okay. Here's how it went down. Anne was a performer at UCB. And she said that there was a request for female performers
非常恩爱，对吧？而且他们在所有其他被删掉的场景里也出现了。他们总是处于某种拥抱的状态。我有点对他们着迷了。我就想，这个女人是真的怀孕了吗？他们是被当作情侣雇来的吗？这里面有什么故事？所以我做了一点深入挖掘。好吧。我发现这个女人是一个叫安·马多克斯（Anne Maddox）的女演员。然后我发现安·马多克斯是我们制片人科迪的朋友。什么？他们在Instagram上是朋友。我深入挖掘了。我就想，我怎么能通过这个叫安的女人搭上线呢？所以科迪联系了她的朋友，她回答了我所有的问话。哦，把全过程告诉我。我想知道。告诉我吧。好吧。事情是这样的。安是UCB（友善喜剧剧团）的演员。她说当时有一个征集，需要女演员
to come in for a role on the office. She was not pregnant in real life. But the role was for a young pregnant woman working nights alongside her baby daddy. And it was scripted that this couple would be lovey-dovey and affectionate constantly. So she auditioned, she got the role and then she got paired with this other actor randomly. But here's what she said. She said, I remember that one of the cameramen did not know that the cuddling was in the script. And he kept saying to me and my co-star, you guys are so affectionate. And then he turned to the other camera operator and said, they've been like this all day. It's so funny. And she was like, no, it was scripted. It was scripted. She also remembered that they shot in the LA Times building. She remembered that we had amazing food
来《办公室》里客串一个角色。她现实生活中并没有怀孕。但这个角色是一个年轻的孕妇，晚上和她的孩子他爸一起工作。剧本里写着这对情侣会非常恩爱，而且一直表现得很亲密。所以她去试镜了，得到了这个角色，然后她被随机分配和另一个男演员搭档。但她是这么说的。她说，我记得其中一个摄影师不知道拥抱是剧本里写的。他一直对我和我的搭档说，你们俩太亲热了。然后他转过身对另一个摄像操作员说，他们一整天都这样。这太搞笑了。而她当时就想，不，这是剧本写的。这是剧本写的。她还记得他们是在《洛杉矶时报》大楼里拍摄的。她记得我们的食物棒极了，
and that the cast and crew were so nice. But she said what's so heartwarming to her about that memory is just how everyone on set treated her like a friend. The crew, the cast, she said she just had the best time of her life and she'll cherish the experience forever. It was so nice. I love that. I also love what a very specific thing that Paul did. Paul was so thoughtful in filling out the world at the telemarketing company that he wrote in the script that there would be a young pregnant woman and her baby daddy and that was so specific. Yeah. I love that we often did that on the show where even minor characters who show up for just one episode, they have a story. That's so great. I just love it. Yeah. And there were a lot of deleted scenes. There's a lot of scenes you don't
而且演员和剧组人员都太友好了。但她说，关于那段记忆最温暖人心的是，片场每个人都把她当成朋友一样对待。剧组，演员，她说她度过了她一生中最美好的时光，她会永远珍惜这段经历。太好了。我喜欢这样。我也很喜欢保罗做的一件非常具体的事情。保罗在完善电话推销公司的世界观时非常周到，他在剧本里写道，会有一个年轻的孕妇和她的孩子他爸，这真是太具体了。Yeah。我喜欢我们在剧场经常这样做，即使是只出现一集的次要角色，他们也有一个故事。这太棒了。我太喜欢了。Yeah。而且有很多被删掉的场景。有很多场景你
see of this couple and of all these people interacting with Michael. Yes. This couple loved Michael. They invited him out to dinner. There's a deleted scene with it. And once again, Jenna, I feel like our set decorators were having fun because there's all of these cartoon clippings. So many. So many. And then there's a white piece of paper that says constant, continuous, Roger demands. Don't know. Don't know. Very strange. I saw it too. I don't know what it means. Well, Alan Wasserman, as Nick Viggo wrote, was fantastic. I thought he was perfect. I loved his whole make the call, say the lines, make the sale. He was just like, I believe him 100% that he was this guy. Well, you know, Ange, in addition to being
看不到这对情侣和所有这些人与迈克尔互动。是的。这对情侣很喜欢迈克尔。他们邀请他出去吃晚饭。有一个相关的被删掉的场景。而且再一次，珍娜，我觉得我们的布景师玩得很开心，因为到处都是卡通剪报。好多。好多。然后还有一张白纸上写着：持续的，不断的，罗杰的要求。不知道。不知道。非常奇怪。我也看到了。我不知道这是什么意思。嗯，艾伦·沃瑟曼饰演的尼克·维加罗（Nick Viggo）太棒了。我觉得他完美极了。我喜欢他那套“打电话，念台词，谈成单”的理念。他就像是——我百分之百相信他就是这种人。嗯，你知道，安吉，除了作为一个
a silent magician, I also worked as a telemarketer. And I can tell you that Alan Wasserman's performance is right on. He's like every boss I ever had in my telemarketing days. Well, you know, I worked at 1-800-Dennis as an operator. And I would constantly get in trouble for not saying line number 13 correctly. Oh, yeah, the scripts are very specific, like they've been researched, they've been put through focus groups. My job was to call people and get them to subscribe to the St. Louis Post Dispatch newspaper. And we had a big deal on the Sunday paper, and I was supposed to push the Sunday paper. Well, line 13, if I remember, was something about like, you would say what their element was and tell them the dentist you were
无声魔术师，我还做过电话推销员。我可以告诉你，艾伦·沃瑟曼的表演完全到位。他就像我在电话推销日子里遇到的每一个老板。嗯，你知道，我在1-800-Dennis当过话务员。我经常因为没有正确念出第13行台词而惹麻烦。哦，对了，剧本非常具体，就像它们被研究过一样，经过了焦点小组的测试。我的工作是打电话让人订购《圣路易斯邮政快报》（St. Louis Post Dispatch）报纸。我们在周日报纸上有一个大促销，而我的任务就是推销周日版的报纸。嗯，如果我没记错的话，第13行台词大概是这样的：你要说出他们的痛点，并告诉他们你要把他们推荐给哪个牙医。而且它非常生硬。我记得我会说，你知道吗，听起来我觉得你可能需要根管治疗。我的意思是，那种疼痛听起来就像是脓肿。
going to send them to. And it was so stilted. And I remember I would say like, you know what, it sounds like to me you might need a root canal. I mean, that kind of pain like that sounds like an abscess. And literally my manager would come in waving his arms and he'd be like, you are not a dental professional. You cannot diagnose. You have to say this line exactly. Well, let me help you with that toothache by finding a dentist for you in your area. Like, I can't say sounds like a root canal to me. What are you doing, lady? So I would get in trouble. Well, Jenna, should we get to Shroop Farms? Let's go to Shroop Farms. Jim and Pam are sitting on a couch in what looks like a sort of reception slash lobby area. And Dwight is explaining that there
然后我的经理真的会挥舞着胳膊走进来，说：“你不是牙医专业人士。你不能诊断。你必须一字不差地念这行台词。”“嗯，让我通过在您当地为您找一个牙医来帮您缓解牙痛吧。”就像，我不能说“听起来像个根管治疗”。你在干什么，女士？所以我就会惹麻烦。嗯，珍娜，我们该去施鲁特农场了吗？我们去施鲁特农场吧。吉姆和帕姆坐在一张沙发上，这个地方看起来像是某种接待处兼大堂区域。德怀特正在向他们解释说，
are three types of rooms available. He's checking them in. They can stay in America, irrigation, or nighttime. Pam immediately says irrigation. I mean, without thought, she was so positive. Yeah. I'm curious about nighttime, but I think I would have also chosen irrigation. And by the way, it doesn't disappoint. When Dwight shows them to their room, the irrigation room has a lot of pipes hanging from the walls. It's a wonderful design. Pipes with no purpose, though. No, no, no, it's decor. They're decorative. Yeah. Decorative pipes. Yes. And two twin beds. Yeah. Now, I believe I don't know if there's a deleted scene of it, but there was a scene that we shot where you see that Jim and Pam have pushed the two beds together.
这里有三种类型的房间可供选择。他在为他们登记入住。他们可以住在“美洲”（America）、“灌溉”（Irrigation）或“夜间”（Nighttime）。帕姆立刻说要“灌溉”。我的意思是，不假思索，她太肯定了。Yeah。我对“夜间”很好奇，但我猜我也会选择“灌溉”。而且顺便说一句，它没有让人失望。当德怀特带他们去房间时，灌溉房的墙壁上挂着很多管道。这是一个绝妙的设计。不过是没有实际用途的管道。不，不，不，这是装饰。它们是装饰性的。Yeah。装饰性的管道。是的。还有两张单人床。Yeah。现在，我相信——我不知道有没有被删掉的相关场景，但我们拍过一个场景，你可以看到吉姆和帕姆把两张床推到了一起。
In the morning, you see into the room and Jim and Pam have actually made it one bed. Yes. And I was like, wait, is there two beds or one bed? And then I realized what they had done. Yes. Yes. But I really like this moment on the two beds with Jim and Pam when Jim says one in six. And Pam's like, what? And he's like, oh, I'm sorry. I thought you asked me, what are our chances of being murdered tonight? Yeah. And Jim has this really sweet talking head where he says he had this whole vision of what it would be like to have a weekend away with Pam. What our first trip away would be like. It's so romantic, really, and sweet. And he said it definitely would not have been wine made out of beets, probably not with Dwight, and definitely not with so much manure.
到了早上，你可以看到房间里面，吉姆和帕姆实际上把它变成了一张大床。是的。当时我想，等等，这是两张床还是一张床？然后我意识到他们做了什么。是的。是的。但我真的很喜欢吉姆和帕姆在两张床上的这个时刻，当时吉姆说“六分之一”。帕姆就说，什么？然后他说，哦，对不起。我还以为你问我，我们今晚被谋杀的几率是多少。Yeah。吉姆有一个非常甜蜜的访谈镜头，他说他曾对和帕姆一起度过一个周末有过各种美好的设想。我们的第一次旅行会是什么样的。这真的很浪漫，很甜蜜。他说，这绝对不会是拿甜菜做的红酒，大概不会和德怀特在一起，也绝对不会有这么多的粪肥。
Yeah. Maybe some manure, but less manure. Yeah. And we filmed all of these little moments that went under this talking head. So you see Dwight mashing up beets to make beet wine, and then you see us out in the field helping to shovel this manure. And then Moe's gets into a manure, like a snowball fight with Dwight, but he's throwing manure. And I remember shooting all of that. We had a fan question from Matthew K. When Dwight and Pam are shoveling manure, was it real? And was the moment when Moe starts throwing manure at Dwight scripted, or was that just Mike sure messing with rain? Okay, it was not real manure, right? It was not. Of course not. Yeah. No. Fakie manure. Put it on our list. Yes. And it was scripted, this idea, this little
Yeah。也许可以有一点粪肥，但少一点。Yeah。我们拍了所有这些藏在这个访谈镜头下的小片断。所以你会看到德怀特捣碎甜菜来做甜菜酒，然后你会看到我们在田野里帮忙铲这些粪肥。然后莫斯和德怀特玩起了粪肥——就像打雪仗一样，但他扔的是粪肥。我记得拍摄所有这些。我们收到了来自马修·K（Matthew K.）的粉丝提问。当德怀特和帕姆在铲粪肥时，那是真的吗？莫斯开始向德怀特扔粪肥的那一刻是剧本里写好的，还是只是迈克·舒尔在捉弄雷恩？好吧，那不是真的粪肥，对吧？不是的。当然不是。Yeah。不是。假粪肥。把它加入我们的列表。是的。这是剧本写好的，这个主意，这个小小的
snowball fight of manure that was in the script. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. So yeah, Fakie Poo, I wonder what it was made of. It was just like dirt, and there was some hay inside of it and stuff. It was just like a muddy kind of mess. Right. So they probably could really pelt each other. They probably could hurt. Yes. Lady, I want to point something out about this episode. And this scene here, when we're shoveling the manure, is really your best look at it. Here is my thing. What the f am I wearing? I know. Did you look at my outfit in this episode? What is it? My pants look waterproof. Well, also, they don't fit. They're too long. They're all baggy. They go over your shoes. They look like a pair of very hip hugger, waterproof cargo pants. I don't know. And a very, very
粪肥雪仗，剧本里是有的。哦，Yeah。哦，Yeah。所以，是的，假便便，我不知道它是用什么做的。它就像是泥土，里面还有一些干草之类的东西。它只是一团泥泞的乱七八糟的东西。对吧。所以他们大概真的可以猛砸对方。那可能会弄伤人。是的。女士，我想指出关于这一集的某件事。这里的这个场景，当我们铲粪肥时，真的是你最好的特写。我的问题是：我特么穿的是什么？我知道。你看我在这一集里的穿着了吗？那是什么？我的裤子看起来像防水的。嗯，而且，它们并不合身。太长了。全都是松垮垮的。一直垂到鞋子外面。它们看起来像是一条非常低腰的防水工装裤。我不知道。还有一件非常、非常
ill-fitted sweater. I know. And also, did we not alter anything? Did Pam not want to look cute on Pam? Well, lady. I think you look very cute later in your gray tank top, though. You look very cute. I do look really cute in my gray tank top. You do. You do. I thought you looked... I was like, aw, Jenna looks so cute. But this outfit is a hot mess. It really, really is. Well, you mentioned my little tank top, Angela. And first of all, I don't sleep in clothes like that. I sleep completely dressed. Lee calls it my sleeping suit. He's like, it's amazing how you've covered up all of your skin from your neck down to your wrists, down to your ankles. Because I get cold at night. We've discussed. But Pam is in the cutest little tank top and pajama pants. It was freezing in
不合身的毛衣。我知道。而且，我们没有改过任何衣服吗？帕姆难道不想在帕姆身上看起来很可爱吗？好吧，女士。不过我觉得你后来穿灰色背心的时候看起来很可爱。你看起来很可爱。我穿灰色背心的时候确实看起来很可爱。你确实。你确实。我觉得你看起来——我就想，啊，珍娜看起来太可爱了。但这套衣服真是一团糟。真的，真的是。嗯，你提到了我的小背心，安吉拉。首先，我睡觉不穿那样的衣服。我睡觉时裹得严严实实的。李（Lee）把它叫做我的“睡眠套装”。他说，太神奇了，你把从脖子到手腕、再到脚踝的所有皮肤都遮得严严实实。因为我晚上会冷。我们讨论过。但帕姆穿着最可爱的小背心和睡裤。那栋楼里冷得要命。
that building. But it's a really cute moment because Dwight is reading them a bedtime story. He's reading them Harry Potter. And Jim and Pam are snuggling and Moses listening. It's sweet and awkward all at the same time. Well, we had a fan question, a lot of fan questions about the Harry Potter book. Was he really reading? Yada, yada. Well, Emma H has come to our rescue. And she says, I am currently rereading the Harry Potter series. And I just happened to come across the page that Dwight reads to Jim and Pam. It is page 85 from the Deathly Hollows book. It is the scene when Voldemort is interrogating Ollivander and the wandmaker. Now, I'm sorry if I stumbled through that, but I am not familiar with this series. This falls into the Star Wars area for me.
但这是一个非常温馨的时刻，因为德怀特在给他们读睡前故事。他在读《哈利·波特》。吉姆和帕姆依偎在一起，莫斯也在听。既甜蜜又尴尬。嗯，我们有一个粉丝提问，有很多关于《哈利·波特》书的粉丝提问。他真的在读吗？巴拉巴拉。嗯，艾玛·H（Emma H.）来拯救我们了。她说，我目前正在重读《哈利·波特》系列。我刚好翻到了德怀特读给吉姆和帕姆听的那一页。那是《死亡圣器》书中的第85页。那是伏地魔审问奥利凡德和这位制杖师的场景。现在，如果我磕磕绊绊地读过去，我很抱歉，因为我对这个系列不熟悉。这对我来说属于《星球大战》的范畴。
Okay, Jenna. Okay. Well, did I say those names right? Voldemort? Isn't that the person you're not supposed to say? Yes, exactly. And Ollivander. Well, that is fantastic. I love to know where that is in the book. So thanks for that catch, Emma. And before we move away from this lovely Harry Potter reading, Jenna, here's my thing about Pam's outfit. What? Pam is doing what you do at the beginning of a relationship where you're still trying to look cute at bedtime. That will pass. Maybe that's what she really sleeps in. I need to know this actually. Whenever I watch TV shows or movies and women are in the morning, they're in, like, getting coffee in the morning or they're going to bed at night, they're always dressed in
好的，珍娜。好的。嗯，我那些名字读对了吗？伏地魔？那难道不是那个名字都不能说的人吗？是的，完全正确。还有奥利凡德。嗯，那太棒了。我很想知道那是书中的哪个地方。所以谢谢你找到这个，艾玛。在我们离开这个可爱的《哈利·波特》朗读环节之前，珍娜，这是我对帕姆着装的看法。什么？帕姆在做你在恋爱初期会做的事，那时你睡觉时还想保持可爱。那会过去的。也许那就是她真正睡觉时的穿着。我其实很想知道这一点。每当我看到电视剧或电影里，女人们在早晨，比如早晨起来喝咖啡，或者晚上准备睡觉时，她们总是穿着
these, like, little pajamas with the little shorts and the little tank tops or something. I don't know. Sometimes women are wearing, like, like, what are those things like silk and shift dress things to bed? Lingerie? Lingerie? Not full lingerie, but like, you know, what are they called? They're like silk or satin. What are they called? I don't know. But I used to have little tank top and short combos. I would get them at Target, like pajamas. And in the summer, I would sleep in shorts. I mean, because you know, I'm always going to have my place nice and warm. Sam just wrote a slip. Yeah, like a slip dress thing. Yes. Like a silky, slippy dress pajama thing. Who sleeps in that? Anyone out there, literally any woman listening,
这些，像是小短裤和小背心之类的小睡衣。我不知道。有时候女人们会穿着，像是——那些东西叫什么来着，丝绸吊带裙之类的去睡觉？内衣？内衣？不是全套内衣，但是，你知道，它们叫什么？它们是丝绸或缎子的。它们叫什么？我不知道。但我以前有过小背心和短裤的套装。我会在塔吉特（Target）买它们，当睡衣。而在夏天，我会穿着短裤睡觉。我的意思是，因为你知道，我总是要把我的地方弄得暖烘烘的。山姆刚刚打字写了“吊带裙”。Yeah，就像吊带裙那种东西。是的。就像丝绸的、滑溜溜的裙子睡衣那种东西。谁会穿着那个睡觉？外面有人吗，字面意义上任何听节目的女性，
have you ever slept in one of those when you weren't trying to impress a man? Just like, this is what I love to sleep in. This is my go-to. I love to sleep in a silk slip. Yeah. Negligé. Negligé. Yes. Negligé. Who sleeps in a negligé for reals? Well, there was a time in my life I would have slept in a tank top in shorts, but now I live with a mountain man who freezes me out. And I'm sorry, those days are gone. I'm fully, I'm in my sleep suit, Jenna. All right. Well, so everybody is winding down for the night at Shroop Farms. Michael is still at work. He still telemarketing, but it's time for his dinner break. Yes, it's dinner time. And his cubicle mate right next to him is Vikram. Vikram
你曾经在不是为了给男人留下深刻印象的时候穿过那种睡觉吗？就只是，我喜欢穿着这个睡觉。这是我的首选。我喜欢穿着丝绸吊带裙睡觉。Yeah。轻薄睡衣（Negligé）。轻薄睡衣。是的。轻薄睡衣。谁真的会穿着轻薄睡衣睡觉？嗯，我生命中曾有过一段时间，我会穿着背心和短裤睡觉，但我现在和一个把我冻得够呛的山顶洞人住在一起。而且抱歉，那些日子已经一去不复返了。我全身包裹严实，我穿着我的睡眠套装，珍娜。好吧。那么，每个人都在施鲁特农场准备休息过夜。迈克尔还在工作。他还在做电话推销，但到了他的晚饭时间了。是的，是晚饭时间。坐在他隔壁的隔间同事是维克拉姆（Vikram）。维克拉姆
is played by Ranjit Chaudhry. He does such a phenomenal job. I thought it was perfect. Everything he said as an actor, he just sort of threw it away, you know, and it, I just thought he was a phenomenal actor. And I just thought he crushed all of his scenes. It was so believable. Vikram is eating mixed masala and eggplant and rice. His dinner looks amazing. And it looks like it was prepared with love and it's in all these little nice containers. And Michael is having a vanilla crisp bar. Yes. Which is a real thing. It's a power bar. Yeah. Yeah. But what you see is that, you know, well, Jan doesn't know where Michael is, but she certainly hasn't sent him to work with a lovely meal. The way Vikram's partner clearly has. Ranjit, very sadly, he passed away
由兰吉特·乔杜里（Ranjit Chaudhry）饰演。他表现得太出色了。我觉得他完美极了。作为一个演员，他说的一切他都好像是随口带过，你知道的，而且，我只是觉得他是一个非凡的演员。我觉他演的所有场景都演绝了。太可信了。维克拉姆在吃混合玛莎拉（mixed masala）、茄子和米饭。他的晚饭看起来棒极了。看起来是用心准备的，装在所有这些 nice 的小容器里。而迈克尔吃的是香草脆皮能量棒。是的。那是真实存在的东西。那是一种能量棒。Yeah。Yeah。但你看到的是，你知道，嗯，简不知道迈克尔在哪里，但她绝对没有给他准备一顿像样的工作餐。就像维克拉姆的伴侣显然为他准备的那样。兰吉特，非常悲伤的是，他在去年四月去世了。和他合作太棒了。
in April of last year. He was so great to work with. And guys, he's going to come back for another episode. You might remember he is part of Michael's dream team when Michael starts the Michael Scott paper company. So I got to work with him when he came back. And I got a few facts on him because I just thought he was so wonderful. You know, his mother was a theater teacher and an actress. His stepfather was a theater director. And he just he worked his whole life as an actor and a writer. And he just had this very long career as an artist and comes from a long line of artists. So he's just amazing. I loved watching him in his scenes. I agree. Well, after they have dinner, Michael is sort of holding court with the other telemarketers.
伙计们，他还会回来客串另一集。你可能还记得，当迈克尔创办迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司时，他是迈克尔梦之队的一部分。所以我得以和他合作，当他回来的时候。我收集了一些关于他的资料，因为我真的觉得他太棒了。你知道，他的母亲是一位戏剧老师和演员。他的继父是一位戏剧导演。他一辈子都在当演员和作家。他作为艺术家有着非常长的职业生涯，并且出身于艺术家世家。所以他太棒了。我很喜欢看他在剧中的表演。我同意。嗯，吃完晚饭后，迈克尔和别的电话推销员聚在一起成了中心人物。
They love him. He's talking about Die Hard and how Die Hard won the original. John McClain was just this normal guy, you know, he's just a New York City cop. And then he gets his feet cut and gets beat up. Jenna, I had just watched Die Hard over the holidays. We were picking Christmas movies and it's a kind of a great Christmas movie. It's one of my favorite Christmas movies. And right out of the gate, Josh turns to me and goes, I would have put my shoes on. The minute I heard gunfire, I would have put my shoes on. This was a really hard thing for Josh to get past that this guy had no shoes on for like the whole movie. And also, also, he takes the shoes off this enormously tall Nordic guy, right? He's just died, massive dude.
他们很喜欢他。他在谈论《虎胆龙威》（Die Hard）以及《虎胆龙威》第一部是如何经典的。约翰·麦克莱恩（John McClain）只是个普通人，你知道，他只是个纽约市警察。然后他的脚被割伤，挨了打。珍娜，我刚刚在假期里看了一遍《虎胆龙威》。我们在挑选圣诞电影，它其实是一部很棒的圣诞电影。它是我最喜欢的圣诞电影之一。结果刚开始看，乔许就转向我说：“我会把鞋子穿上的。”一听到枪声，我就会把鞋子穿上。这对乔许来说是个很难过去坎，就是这个家伙一整部电影基本上都没穿鞋。而且，而且，他从这个无比高大的北欧家伙脚上脱下了鞋子，对吧？那家伙刚死，是个大块头。
And he's like, shoes are too small. And we're like, okay, we're going to call BS on that. There's no way that dude's feet are smaller than yours, Bruce Willis. What's happening? Yeah. Well, you know, and then the thing happens in this movie that's real hard for me, where he gets the piece of glass in his foot, and he does not take care of that properly. He just does not. No. But it's, I mean, I know he doesn't have a lot of options, but that kind of stuff, it just, ooh, it gets you. Well, anyway, everyone is loving Michael's theory on Die Hard and the Die Hard series. And one of the co workers is like, dude, you should review movies. They're like, yeah. And then Michael's like, actually, I'm writing a movie.
而他说，鞋子太小了。我们当时就觉得，好吧，我们要对这个说法打个问号。那家伙的脚怎么可能比你的还小，布鲁斯·威利斯（Bruce Willis）？这怎么可能？Yeah。好吧，你知道，然后电影里发生了对我来说很难接受的一幕，他脚上扎了一块玻璃，而他并没有好好处理。他真的没有。没有。但是，我的意思是，我知道他没有太多选择，但那种事情，真的，噢，太折磨人了。无论如何，大家都喜欢迈克尔对《虎胆龙威》和《虎胆龙威》系列的理论。其中一个同事就说，老兄，你应该去写电影评论。他们就说，对啊。然后迈克尔就像是，其实，我正在写一部电影。
Yeah. Threat level midnight. Yeah. And they're like, oh, ooh. But I just think it's so incredibly charming that Michael is like, he's the cool dude. I know. He's the cool dude at this place. I know. Well, back at Shroop Farms, Pam hears a very strange knocking noise. She decides to investigate. And it's Mo's in an outhouse, an outhouse, and the wind is blowing the door, whack, whack, whack. And Pam is like, what century is this? I know. Well, Paul told me this is one of his favorite shots from this episode, because it's all one long tracking shot, and they had to time it out. They had to, you know, rack focus from Pam out to the outhouse. And poor Mike sure had to sit out there and just wait for us every time
Yeah。《头号危机》（Threat Level Midnight）。Yeah。然后他们就说，哦，噢。但我只是觉得迈克尔这样子真的难以置信的迷人，他就是那个酷小伙。我知道。他是这个地方的酷小伙。我知道。好吧，回到施鲁特农场，帕姆听到了一声非常奇怪的敲击声。她决定去查看一下。原来是莫斯在一个简易厕所（outhouse）里，在一个简易厕所里，风把门吹得砰、砰、砰地响。帕姆就说，这是哪个世纪？我知道。好吧，保罗告诉我这是他这一集中最喜欢的镜头之一，因为这全是一个长镜头，他们必须掌握好时间。他们必须，你知道，将焦点从帕姆转移到简易厕所上。可怜的迈克尔·舒尔不得不坐在那里，每次我们重新拍摄时都要等着我们。
we would reset. I mean, again, put through the ringer in this episode, you know, it was cold out there. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Now I want to point out, in an earlier episode, when Dwight is telling us about Shroop Farms, he says that there's only one bathroom and it's under the porch. Oh, nice catch. So I like to think that maybe when he decided to do the BNB, he upgraded to an outhouse. A proper outhouse. Yes. This is my backstory for the Shroop Farms outhouse. So they figure out what that sound is. So now Jim and Pam are going to go back to bed. But now there's like a wailing, like a moaning. Yes. I mean, it's like, what is that noise? And so Jim, it's like his turn. So he's going to check it out. Well, at 15 minutes, 40 seconds, he approaches
我的意思是，再次在这个集里受尽折磨，你知道，外面很冷。哦，Yeah。哦，Yeah。现在我想指出，在早些时候的一集中，当德怀特向我们介绍施鲁特农场时，他说只有一个洗手间，而且在门廊底下。哦，好眼光。所以我愿意相信，当他决定开办加早餐旅馆（B&B）时，他升级到了简易厕所。一个像样的简易厕所。是的。这就是我对施鲁特农场简易厕所的前情背景设定。所以他们弄清楚那个声音是什么了。现在吉姆和帕姆要回床上去睡觉了。但现在有了一种像哭喊一样、像呻吟一样的声音。是的。我的意思是，那是什么声音？所以吉姆，轮到他了。所以他要去查看一下。嗯，在15分40秒时，他走近
a door. Did you notice the wooden plaque says private room? Yes. Right? Yes. He goes in and Dwight is holding the chair figurine and moaning. But very briefly, and I'm talking very briefly, at 15 minutes, 52 seconds over Jim's shoulder, you can see a little bit of a poster. And I zoomed in on this poster. And the legs, it looks like a rock and roll band. And the legs of the pants are white with gray stripes, like skin tight pants. You can't really make out the face. But I got obsessed with these pants. And I started looking up every motley crew poster I could find because I'm positive it's motley crew, right? It's Dwight. Okay. It's got to be motley crew. I'm telling you it is. I found a photo of Tommy Lee in the same white skin tight stripy pants.
了一扇门。你注意到木质牌匾上写着“私人房间”了吗？是的。对吧？是的。他走了进去，德怀特正拿着椅子雕像在呻吟。但非常短暂地，我是说非常短暂地，在15分52秒吉姆的肩膀上方，你可以看到一点海报。我把这张海报放大了。那些腿，看起来像一支摇滚乐队。裤子的腿是白色的，带有灰色条纹，就像紧身裤一样。你看不太清脸。但我对这条裤子着迷了。我开始查找我能找到的每一张莫特莉·克鲁（Motley Crue）的海报，因为我确信那是莫特莉·克鲁，对吧？那是德怀特。好吧。那一定是个莫特莉·克鲁。我跟你说一定是。我找到了一张汤米·李（Tommy Lee）穿着同样白色紧身条纹裤的照片。
And there is no doubt in my mind that in the private room, the love sanctuary of Angela and Dwight, that there is a motley crew poster. If you remember on their album, Decade of Decadence 81-91, there's a song called Angela. It's going to come into play later. Sam, hit it. Wow. Yeah, that poster of motley crew, you know what that means to Dwight. It's his lady, it's his heavy metal and fans that have watched the show all the way through. I don't want to do any spoilers. That song is going to come back in a big way later. Wow. Wow. Well, I'll tell you what I noticed in this scene. At 16 minutes, we have got a huge Dwight from Jim. But then at the end
我毫不怀疑，在安吉拉和德怀特的私人房间、爱之圣殿里，有一张莫特莉·克鲁的海报。如果你还记得他们专辑《十年沉沦81-91》（Decade of Decadence 81-91）里，有一首歌叫《安吉拉》（Angela）。这首歌稍后会派上用场。山姆，放出来。哇。Yeah，那张莫特莉·克鲁的海报，你知道那对德怀特意味着什么。那是他的女士，那是他的重金属。把整部剧看完的粉丝们。我不想剧透。那首歌稍后会以一种重磅的方式回归。哇。哇。嗯，我来告诉你我在这场戏中注意到了什么。在16分钟时，吉姆说了一个巨大的“德怀特”（Dwight）。但随后在场景结束时，当他离开房间时，他蹦出了一个普通的“德怀特”（Dwight）。不，我们在同一个场景里有一个“Dwight”和一个“Dwight”。他从来不说“Dwight”。他总是说“Dwight”。这是约翰唯一一次说“Dwight”吗？嗯，我听了好几遍。哦，天哪，因为这就是我们的工作。你在反反复复地听那个。与此同时，我却在谷歌上搜索诸如“摇滚乐队裤子”之类的东西。嗯，我觉得他说的是“Dwight”，就像“Dwight”一样。但这已经是我们能听到的最接近“Dwight”的发音了。好吧。嗯，伙计们，在我们这里结束之前，我们还有最后一个场景。那是迈克尔工作日的结束。他正走在外面。每个人都邀请他一起去酒吧。来吧，迈克尔，我们想多花点时间陪你。Yeah。但他不能。Yeah，简来接他了。她
of the scene, when he's leaving the room, he throws out a regular Dwight. No, we have a Dwight and a Dwight in the same scene. He never said Dwight. He always said Dwight. Is this the one time John says Dwight? Well, I listened to it several times. Oh my gosh, because this is our job. You're listening to that over and over. Meanwhile, I'm Google searching like rock and roll band pants. Well, I think he says Dwight, like Dwight. But it's the closest thing to a Dwight we're going to get. Okay. Well, guys, before we finish up here, we've got one last scene. It's the end of Michael's work day. And he's walking outside. Everyone's inviting him to come to the bar with him. Come on, Michael, we want to spend more time with you. Yeah. But he can't. Yeah, Jan has come to pick him up. She
下了车，她说：“你来开。我喝了太多酒。”太棒了。很高兴你开车来这儿。Yeah。我也这么想。然后迈克尔问：“瑜伽怎么样？”她回答：“我没去。”他问：“为什么？”她回答：“我就是没去。”哦，哦，太悲伤了。简的螺旋式坠落，伙计。她要把迈克尔也一起拖下水。Yeah。然后维克拉姆告诉迈克尔：“听着，伙计，只要你再努力一点，你也许就能拿到那笔奖金了。”维克拉姆在最后做了一次鼓舞士气的谈话。他说：“只要按剧本办就行。”Yeah。Yeah。哦，迈克尔。嗯，我很喜欢这一集。我很喜欢剖析这第一部分。我等不及要看下一部分了。非常感谢大家发来你们的问题。我和，吉姆和我简直爱死做这个了。我们就是爱它。我们爱它。好吧，我们下周见，聊聊《钱》（下集）。《钱》（下集）。感谢收听《办公室女郎》。《办公室女郎》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）担任执行制片人。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音响工程师是山姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫（Ainsley Bubakow）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡皮树》（Rubber Tree）。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女郎》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用代码“Office”。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
gets out of the car and she says, you drive. I've had too much wine. Great. Glad you drove here. Yeah. Thought the same thing. And then Michael's like, how was yoga? She's like, I didn't go. And he's like, why? And she's like, I just didn't. Oh, oh, so sad. The Jan spiral man. And she's going to take Michael down with her. Yeah. And then Vikram tells Michael, listen, man, you might be able to nab that bonus if you just work a little harder. Vikram gives a, you know, a little pep talk there at the end. He's like, just stick to the script. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, Michael. Well, I love this episode. I love breaking down this first part. I can't wait to get to the next part. And thank you so much,
下车后她说，你来开，我喝了太多酒。太棒了，很高兴是你开车来的。对啊，我也这么想。然后迈克尔问，瑜伽怎么样？她说，我没去。迈克尔问为什么，她说，就是没去。哦，哦，太惨了。简彻底失控了，她还要把迈克尔也拉下水。对。然后维克拉姆对迈克尔说，听着，老兄，你只要再加把劲，说不定就能拿到那个奖金了。维克拉姆最后给了他一点鼓励，你知道的。他说，照着剧本念就行。对。哦，迈克尔。我真的很喜欢这一集，我喜欢剖析这第一部分，我已经迫不及待想进入下一部分了，非常感谢
everyone for sending in your questions. And I, we just, Jim and I just freaking love doing this. We just love it. We love it. All right. Well, we will see you next week for Money Part Two. Money Part Two. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
大家发来问题。我和吉姆真是太喜欢做这个了。我们就是喜欢。我们非常喜欢。好了，那我们下周再见，继续聊《钱》（下集）。《钱》（下集）。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制作人是英斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。注册 Stitcher Premium 可享一个月免费试用，使用优惠码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。